esta que viene aquí en las pantallas a
mi derecha y la izquierda es la pared de
mi cuarto y re visto durante estas dos
semanas se ha convertido en mi insomnio
pensando en este preciso instante en
esta alfombra de la cual no me tengo que
salir
no sabía cómo empezar a contarles esta
historia y creo que a veces nos pasa que
pensamos que las ideas surgen de un
brainstorming sí y surgen de hombres
orden pero no todos se nos ocurre una
idea ahí
la siguiente historia es sobre cómo a
veces hay que
tocar fondo para recoger ese pausa que
se quedó escondido todo esto empieza
cuando yo tenía 21 22 años
creo que creo que empieza desde hace
mucho mucho antes yo era el dolor de
cabeza de mi mamá soy la consecuencia de
sus migrañas
no se rían porque es verdad está sentada
y está sintiendo en este momento
y esto pasa porque yo me retiré dos
carreras
quisiera echarle la culpa de la
educación en nuestro país pero fue mi
responsabilidad me salí a estas dos
carreras porque no sabía que quería
estudiar me metí sin pensarlo
e intenté tener varios proyectos varios
emprendimientos uno de ellos era comprar
cosas por internet y revender más según
yo había inventado la pólvora mentira
todo el mundo me baste pero yo pensé que
era una gran idea me acuerdo inclusive
que pedir prestada plata y terminé
endeudándome entonces pedía más para
pagar está y me sigue endeudando es mal
hábito
es algo que me costó aprender porque
después me tocó enfrentarlo con tarjetas
y yo creía que se pagaban solas grave
error de nuestra generación las deudas
con las tarjetas entonces teniendo todo
esto pasando todo esto al mismo tiempo
me escapaba de la casa era muy rebelde
clasificaba las notas esta es la cruda
verdad yo era de rebelde pero en ese
momento no tenía causa simplemente
querían la contra todo el mundo y en
este momento en mi vida 21 22 años me
doy cuenta por tres pruebas de embarazo
y las tres salieron positivas entonces y
el momento dejarme tonteras pensé voy a
pagar mis deudas voy a ser muy buena en
mi chamba voy a empezar a ahorrar
voy a portarse bien voy a dejar las
escapadas a la mañana y me perseguían
con el carro y según yo me gané se está
dando cuenta
pero no fue tan sencillo como
simplemente decir listo se acabó porque
dos meses y un par de semanas después me
desperté para ir a trabajar y me
desperté con curioso pero es mi cama
estaba tan roja como esta alfombra
y creo que entendemos qué significa eso
significa que se perdió algo en ese rojo
yo no sé si la primera palabra que
aprendí a decir fue mamá pero pero en
ese momento la gente y ella vino
corriendo me miró con mucha tristeza
entonces
me di cuenta que ya estaba dicho en esa
mirada de hecho conversando aquí con
alguno de los otros speakers me di
cuenta que es es algo que le pasa a
muchas mujeres y a veces no nos damos
cuenta del acompañamiento y el apoyo que
necesitamos cuando estas cosas pasan
cuando sucedió esta pérdida me fui a la
clínica
el médico me dijo como si fuera pues un
partido de pelota para haber perdido no
voy a estar no te preocupes joven vas a
poner tener otro estas cosas pasan estas
cosas pasan y pasan pero pero no se van
casi tan fácil recuerdo que salí de esta
clínica y me fuma una cajetilla de
cigarros al hilo no aparece para esto
cuando estaba embarazada había alguna
forma no había falta se había comido muy
bien
y ella mi casa y mi mamá lo único que me
dijo fue las cosas pasan por algo no me
dijo más porque sabía que yo no
necesitaba escuchar más solo está
recorriendo mi cuarto y a cerrar me
encantó el tema es que a veces no
sabemos aceptar la mano que nos quiere
ayudar y terminamos apoyándonos en un
objeto en una persona que es muy nociva
para nosotros y eso fue lo que me pasó
después de esta pérdida me aferré a una
relación que tenía como ciertos
requisitos para mí tenía que dejar de
maquillarme porque eso significaba
querer llamar la atención tenía que
comer me tenía que seguir una dieta
vegana pero como yo no tenía un
nutricionista y en mi casa nadie
vegetariano simplemente corte la carne
el pollo y el pescado entonces
imagínense comer arroz papas y las
verduras que habían en la casa como
estaba físicamente después porque eso lo
seguía un año casi un año
había redención a mi trabajo porque se
ponía celoso de la gente con la niña
trabajada
no podría ir al chifa y mirar al mozo
porque él pensaba que eso significaba
que yo lo saco que te 'no tengo un
ticket con los lentes me lo saco me los
pongo los acomodo creo que no es un poco
sueca pero no importa son cosas que hago
pero eso no significa que me estoy
liando quien está enfrente simplemente
son cosas que pasan cosas que hago con
los lentes pero esta persona me hizo muy
chiquita es muy chiquita yo permití que
me haga muy chiquita
sin trabajo sin poder mantenerme
despierta todo el día peleando con mis
amigas porque si salía con ellas
significaba para él que yo estaba
tramando algo tenía mis contraseñas de
facebook de twitter de instagram y de mi
email de todo
una noche me dice que por un mensaje te
se encima de un celular prestado el de
mi mamá me dice que estaba interesado en
alguien más entonces no nos enfoquemos
por favor solamente en ese mensaje de
texto porque ese es el momento en el que
si estas charlas se sube a youtube un
montón de gente va a juzgar para decir
como no te das cuenta como no te diste
cuenta de lo que estaba pasando bueno
uno no se da cuenta cuando está dentro
de la tormenta simplemente baja la
cabeza y sigue y sigue y sigue
cuando eso sucedió
me da mucho roche yo yo no tomo no suelo
tomar soy mala tomando soy el que toma
un poquito y se va el piso y eso fue lo
que pasó
cogí una taza en la que solíamos tomar
café bueno en mi familia nadie tiene el
hábito de licor pero yo cogí esta tasa
porque no quería que sepan que me hace
haber whisky me fui a la sala de cine de
whisky
me termine pues un poco pero terminé
abrazando un water vomitando y
acariciando lo porque ya que más que
nada no este no tenía una carrera no
tenía ahorros estaba endeudada le han
fallado mis amigas a mi familia había
permitido que este hombre me pisen bueno
metafóricamente pero me pisó varias
veces
y encima se estaba viendo como otra
entonces en ese momento abrazando el
water
me acordé cuando tenía 15 en el colegio
y no sé si ustedes están preguntado por
tres de cada cinco o diez años
apóyame con un sí por favor sí
yo a los 15 pensaba que iba a cambiar el
mundo dije que iba a tener un
departamento del año que iba a tener la
caña que iba a tener un matrimonio feliz
probablemente con dos hijos uno adoptado
en él
y atender mi vida resuelta y estaba me
acordé de esto mientras abrazaba el
water y me había dado cuenta que no
había hecho nada había intentado varias
cosas pero no hice nada en realidad sólo
había valorado en la relación con mi
familia había decepcionado a mucha gente
pero más allá de la gente me había hecho
chiquita yo más chiquito de metro 48
mucho más chiquita y
cuando esto pasó tuve dos opciones
me lanza el whisky todo el whisky de mi
mamá y luego lo llenaba con pep para que
no se dé cuenta que no haya tomado el
whisky o decidí hacer un borrón y cuenta
nueva
y de hecho me fui pero segundo pero no
fue tan sencillo como suelo decir bueno
bueno empezar y ya está se borraron
todas mis heridas no tuve que hacer un
borrón y cuenta nueva todos los días
cuando no podía comer porque cuando uno
corta los todas las carnes pollos en el
pescado huevo leche todo comes y vomitar
entonces mi mamá estaba ahí
me obligan a comer e inclusive muchas
veces me la comí en la boca se
preocupaba por que me despertara está o
no no sé como mi mamá pudo soportar todo
eso mis hermanos también me dejan
post-its en la puerta sigue adelante por
favor no te rindas como no quería que la
puerta metía por debajo de mi puerta
hojas bond con sus letras de niños
porque en esa época eran niños que
decían si adelante no te rindas todas
estas frases que a veces nosotros no
necesitamos pero no no lo aceptamos
fue duro este este proceso incluso luego
empecé a ir a terapia porque no es que
simplemente uno decida cambiar y ya está
el acompañamiento que viene consigo no
hasta que una vez llegaron mis amigas a
visitarme yo no recuerdo haberles
escrito no sé si a alguien pues todos y
ellas se pusieron de acuerdo para ir a
verme
pero
y me fueran a visitar y en una
conversación que tuvimos en la playa
nos pusimos al día no les conté que
había terminado con este pata mentira se
había terminado pero seguía respondiendo
le leía sus mensajes veía su foto
entonces está en este proceso de que
tienes al abono y cuenta nueva no no
quiero el borrón y cuenta nueva dónde
está y en esa conversación una de ellas
me dice hoy yo tengo tiempo saliendo con
este pata
pero no sé creo que soy la trampa porque
nunca me lleva a conocer a su familia
y yo le dije oye pero no le he dicho lo
que roche con pensar que soy una intensa
no me lo voy a decir
y amor
esto pasó en la playa
entonces yo le dije ya pero tú tranquila
pagando que no sea tan directo yo lo voy
a publicar en una página en facebook y
tú le vas a compartir
muchacha pero pero solamente esa imagen
no no no puedes voy a poner varias
porque si nos a dar cuenta que eres tú
y esta fue la imagen que salió en ella
existen junto con otras
empezó con frases para dar indirectas
porque no me lleva a cenar con su
familia no entiendo a veces pienso que
son en la trampa no había un hombre no
había un
no había un reclamo era una indirecta
bueno si lo tomas genial pero si no no
era para ti qué pasa el mundo no gira tu
alrededor y teníamos esa facilidad para
saltar y no me di cuenta que no
solamente lo compartía y haciendo que
había muchas que querían compartir esta
imagen y las vivas me mandaban su
mensaje por facebook para que yo lo
diseñe ellas lo publiquen y aquí no pasó
nada yo solamente comparte una imagen en
facebook entonces empezaron a salir
varias varias de canciones americanas
exploramos los frames son juntos para
los que no saben que es la función es el
lugar donde paro toda la vida donde todo
el mundo me quiere como amiga pero hay
uno más soy la brother del grupo
y que sucedió que el tiempo en esta
comunidad empezó a crecer pero me
empezaron a pedir consejos y yo les
decía oye no seas chistosa y es un caos
yo que te voy a decir lo único que te
puedo decir es lo que no debes hacer y
me decían bueno entonces que no hago
bueno no le escribano y esto se trasladó
hacia cafés en persona cambie la casa de
whisky por cafés compartidos escuchamos
en muchas historias historias que me
hicieron reír si historias que me
hicieron llorar
recuerdo una de ellas era una madre
madre soltera y se acababa de enterar
que tenía leucemia que le dices a
alguien que te dice que te pregunta y
ahora qué hago
había una chica de chiclayo que había
encontrado a su mejor amigo tirado en el
piso del cual ella estaba enamorada y el
chico se había metido un balazo que le
respondes a una persona así no tenía ni
idea así que lo único que hice fue
callarme la boca y escucharlas compartir
ese café y recomendarles canciones
libros y películas eso era lo que hacía
le daba canciones libros y películas
los contenidos empezaron a cambiar ellas
ya no necesitaban sólo una frase querían
algo más y entonces les di algo más les
di lo que yo hubiera necesitado en ese
momento cuando no me daba cuenta de lo
que estaba haciendo
les di señales las historias y risas
les di complicidad
y esto se terminó convirtiendo en
contenido que me mandaban ellas ya no
eran solamente indirectas eran mensajes
mensajes que buscaban unirnos y
expresarnos a veces no tenemos las
palabras exactas entonces encontramos
una imagen la bajamos y la tenemos en el
celular y eso se puede convertir en un
aliento móvil pero al viento
esto se convierte en un libro
esta fue la feria del libro del 2014
se convirtió en una segunda edición
y luego alcanzamos el medio millón en
esta comunidad
hoy estamos en facebook estamos en
twitter estamos en instagram
estamos por correo electrónico pero más
allá de estas plataformas digitales
y más allá de contarles solamente de
este proyecto al que amo y dedico todos
mis días sin necesidad de que me paguen
por ello en ese momento pensé que ya
tenía las cosas descifrada dije por algo
me pasó todo por algo fui tan rebelde
por algo me pasó todo mentira tenía que
dar una vuelta tenía que dar una vuelta
aún tenía que reinventar este proyecto y
cuando tuve que plantear este nuevo
propósito para mi comunidad para ellos
dicen
me di cuenta que ahí si los puntos se
conectaban entonces si recordamos la
charla de steve jobs
todo se conectaba en realidad la
violencia psicológica que vive la
pérdida las deudas las malas relaciones
los patrones que se van repitiendo una y
otra vez ya solamente nos hacen más daño
me metí a estudiar counseling
y me metí a estudiar sexología para
acompañarnos en este proceso
y ellos dicen se convirtió en un agente
de cambio porque a veces no reír no es
suficiente a veces necesitamos una
propuesta algo más y empezamos a tocar
temas que hoy le incomoda a muchas
personas no de ustedes sino muchas
decidimos ir contra los estereotipos
decidimos hacer una campaña que era un
manifiesto de yo no me disculpo por ser
como soy no me disculpo por ser femenina
por no ser femenina por ser talla xl por
ser s por ser x s
ya cambiaron los mensajes
empezamos a darle cabida a wendy ramos
por ejemplo cuando sucedió este
lamentable hecho que muchos de ustedes
seguramente cuando sean estoy con el
tiempo y ella dicen dio una vuelta sería
sencillo decirles sí bueno en ocho
millas de cifra de qué se trata este y
por qué le pasaron todas estas cosas
inclusive lanzamos un un ebook de cómo
identificar la violencia a través de
historias reales y violencia psicológica
a veces no nos damos cuenta de que están
pasando hasta que alguien lo dice hoy
eso está mal
pero aunque donde quiero ir con
contarles este breve episodio de mi vida
con los 18 minutos que seguramente ya me
pasé me disculpo por eso yo todavía no
lo tengo claro yo no sé qué es lo que va
a pasar hoy ni mañana ni el próximo año
tengo planes tengo sueños quiero otro
libro pero creo que sí como ustedes han
visto todos aquellos que se han parado
aquí y han tenido un objetivo han tenido
que pasar por muchísimas pruebas
desastres naturales personajes tóxicos
caídas hasta lo más profundo a veces
llegamos a un alto que no sabemos cómo
hemos llegado que queremos llevar a
alguien con nosotros y terminamos
perdiendo los dos muchas cosas pasan en
este camino y creo que
y lo más importante más allá de si
tenemos un objetivo no es que nos
dejemos de avanzar es que vemos el
siguiente paso a pesar que nos tiemble y
nos sube todo como mes una horita y que
la falta de claridad no nos detenga
porque al final siempre las cosas
terminan bien o mejor de lo que pensamos
gracias
[Aplausos]